hello gorgeous Smita dois top of the
world
story of my life I always get the fuzzy
end of the lollipop it's not just the
movies it's the Oscars Sunday live on
ABC hit me cheap I got the moves
I'm Spartacus
frankly my dear I don't give a damn just
when I thought I was out they pulled me
back in it's not just the movies it's
the Oscars Sunday live on ABC I'm Luke
Skywalker I'm here to rescue my name is
bond James Bond frankly my dear I don't
give a damn car Naomi city girl man it's
not just the movies it's the Oscars
Sunday February 25th live on ABC
good evening Clarice Oh Spartacus I'm
Spartacus I know it's you Fredo you
broke my heart you broke my heart
snap out of it think you use enough
dynamite there butch don't guide the man
mrs. Robinson you're trying to seduce me
aren't you forget it Jake it's Chinatown
that will do Pig that will do it's not
just the movies it's the Oscars Sunday
February 25th live on ABC
I could have been a contender I could
have been somebody they call me mr.
Tibbs needed MA top of the world frankly
my dear I don't give a damn what do you
mean I'm funny funny how my a clown do I
amuse you it's not just the movies it's
the Oscars Sunday February 25th live on
ABC all right mr. DeMille I'm ready for
my close-up
good evening Clarice forget it Jake it's
Chinatown don't shove me Harv I'm tired
of being shoved frankly my dear I don't
give a damn I know it was you Fredo you
broke my heart you broke my heart my
name is bond James Bond be talking to me
man
it was Beauty killed the Beast feed it
baa after the world
follow the money badness you're gonna
need a bigger boat excuse me while I
whip this out don't drive the man mrs.
Robinson you're trying to seduce me
aren't you just when I thought I was out
they pulled me back in it's not just the
movies it's the Oscars Sunday February
25th live on ABC rosebud
you